[Music]
Preceding Kusunoki Rentaro Keeping the actual diet
Boon The
Kouki family was scorched by the public recruitment
The scent of horseflies The eyes and scent are passable, but the problem is the feet
Indistinguishable mellowness
Still, the outside Salamandre creates a fragrance
The art of the day Here's the
pitiful thing about this,
then the sin is this match
Uho
I see.
That's right
No. How
is it made into a freeze grinder? It's Sarasuga-risu-chan, isn't it?
Then, the warmth of gently heated sake stands
out 6a.The presence of each other is heightened on the surface of sake of different
temperatures.  Because the day and time are all my seasonings.
Certainly different temperatures
bring out the
best flavors of the ingredients.